(ambient music)
- Okay. Greetings everyone.
Thank you for joining
me on this beautiful day
when there are so many lovely things
that you could be doing outside.
Where did the picnic tables come from?
What's up with the picnic tables?
Where do those.
- [Student] Morse College was closed.
So commons went sideways.
- Okay.
Okay, okay.
- [Student] It went this way.
- Okay.
Right. Class.
So, again, I would take you guys outside
if it weren't for the fact
that there's this technology
which is keeping me fixed right here.
The way that I wanna talk
about the subject today
is to broaden it a bit
and think about the German factor
in Ukrainian political history.
Because the German factor has
a kind of strange shape to it
where actually Germany, German culture,
the German language doesn't mean very much
in Ukrainian history
until quite late in the day,
until the 19th and
especially the 20th century.
And then suddenly it means quite a lot
and most of it quite negative.
Most of it quite destructive.
So, I wanted to start by just
going back over a few of the
themes from previous lectures
just to set the stage for
this kind of sudden on rush
of Germany in Ukrainian history.
Because I have this,
I have the feeling that if I
just start with 1939 or 1941
in a way that will be too abrupt
and we won't understand
the depth of the contrast.
'Cause something new really
begins in the 20th century.
There isn't...
When Germany begins to contact Ukraine,
something new happens
and to see the novelty I think
we have to start earlier on.
So, I'm just gonna now
just do a real quick
series of stopping points
along the previous several centuries.
Oh, sorry, the other thing
I wanna tell you guys
in case you haven't figured
it out is I have a cold,
so I'm at like 85%.
So hopefully I'll go at 85% speed
and that will be more appropriate
and everybody will be happy.
I always feel stupid
when it's nice outside
and I have a cold, right?
(students laughing)
You know what I mean?
I don't feel stupid when it's
like January and I feel great
but when it's like, anyway.
So, what I'm gonna do is I'm gonna review
the last six or seven centuries
and just remind us of some
of the stopping points
that we've marked.
One of them is the Holy Roman Empire.
So if you think back to
the beginning of the class
and the conjuncture in which
the Kyivan state is formed,
Christianity is coming
from two directions,
from the west and from the south,
from the Holy Roman
Empire and from Byzantium.
And roughly speaking,
all of the new states
that are formed then are either
in a relationship to the
Holy Roman Empire like Poland
because Western Christian
or to the Byzantium
because Eastern Christian
or what we're later gonna call orthodoxy.
So, that rivalry, the
presence of Holy Roman Empire
does have something to do with our story.
And that rivalry generated
this contest for Moravia
back in the eighth century
where those gentlemen,
Cyril and Methodius made that
trip northwards to Moravia
and they brought the language with them.
They brought the language with them
which we call Old Church Slavonic.
And they were the ones
who created an alphabet
for Slavic languages.
That has to do with the
German factor in some sense
because it's this contest
between Western and Eastern Christianity,
the friction between them,
which forces people to be creative
and come up with new solutions
like for example, Church Slavonic,
like the Cyrillic language which comes,
the Cyrillic alphabet
which comes a bit later.
It's a bit of a stretch
but I hope you'll buy it
if I say that the Viking factor is also
in some way the Germanic world.
So the Scandinavian languages,
except for Finnish of course,
the Scandinavian languages
are Germanic languages.
And so Kyivan Rus' is
in some way connected
to a broadly speaking Germanic
world by way of Scandinavia,
by way of the Vikings,
by way of the Viking contact
which begins eighth
century, ninth century,
and has to do with the creation of a state
in the 10th and especially
in the 11th century.
And so you can think of
Ukraine as being part of
a kind of crescent of Scandinavian
or Viking state building attempts
which ranges from England
through Scandinavia itself,
and then all the way down to Kyiv.
The next moment which I
didn't really bring out
is the Reformation.
So, the Reformation is largely a German
and then Swiss and then
French event at the beginning.
The Reformation, the emergence
of versions of Christianity
is relevant to Ukraine,
is relevant to our story
because it is that friction between
Protestantism and Catholicism.
The Reformation in later the Catholic,
in later Counter-Reformation,
the Catholic Reformation,
which forces our churchmen in
places like Chernihiv in Kyiv
to take up many languages,
to take up the Renaissance,
to take up Disputation, right?
It is those things which
make those churchmen
in Kyiv, Chernihiv different, for example,
than Churchmen in Moscow
who don't have contact
with the Reformation,
don't have contact with the Renaissance.
And will eventually have
contact with those things
but by way of Kyiv itself.
It's also interesting in that
Protestantism and Orthodoxy
sometimes formed a kind of alliance,
at least a kind of
brief practical alliance
where the Orthodox would
borrow arguments from the,
the Orthodox would borrow arguments
from the Protestants
against the Catholics.
So there was some kind
of cross-fertilization
and there were also very,
there were some very
important Ukrainian families,
families of Ukrainian magnates,
wealthy magnates from old Rus
who converted to Protestantism.
But in general, that only
lasted for one generation
and the next generation they
converted to Catholicism,
and then are remembered
as Polish families.
So, that's interesting.
I hope you agree
but it's relatively meager.
The connection if we compare
it to the connection with
the Grand Duchy of Lithuania
or with Poland, right,
or with Byzantium,
the connection with
Germany is fairly meager
until we get into the modern period,
the modern period of the nation state.
And it's here where Germany
starts to become very important
because Germany's not the most imperial,
most important imperial power in Europe.
Never, right?
Germany, this is a key fact about Germany.
Here come your five minutes
of modern German history.
A key fact about Germany
is that it comes into being
after the world has been colonized.
And this is something that
the Germans themselves
are very aware of.
The German unification of January 1871
takes place at a time when
almost all of the world
that's going to be colonized
is already colonized
from the European point of view.
There are a couple of more decades
of the Race for Africa
that Germany takes part in.
It has colonies in Southeastern
and Southwestern Africa.
But in general, the world has already been
divided up by the time that
Germany becomes a state
in the late 19th century.
So you remember some points on
the basic trajectory of this
that Germany is unified not from Vienna,
not from our Hapsburg
friends, but by Prussia.
I've been trying to
kinda note along the way
in each lecture when Prussia turns up
because eventually Prussia
is going to be important.
The Ducal Prussia breaks
free of Poland in 1657
during a difficult time for Poland,
a few years after the
Cossacks have rebelled
that Prussia declares itself
to be a kingdom in 1701.
And then you may, you remember this fellow
Frederick the Great of Prussia
who's ruling from 1740 to 1780,
he turned up in our class as the rival
of Maria Theresa of Hapsburg,
when Maria Theresa of Hapsburg
becomes the first female
ruler of the Hapsburgs.
He challenges her,
he declares war.
They come to power about the same time,
he immediately declares war as one does
on the logic that he's just
protecting her as one says.
And that period of Prussian history
is the moment when Prussia
begins to gather in
other important lands such as Silesia.
This moment in Prussian history is also,
if I can just make a brief connection
to the history of philosophy,
this is also the moment of
the great German philosopher
Immanuel Kant,
who you just might have
heard of in some other class,
the foundational philosopher
of ethics and many other things
at least in the western
tradition in the modern period.
Kant is the fellow who argued
among many other interesting things
that when you act,
you should act as though
you were making a rule.
So that as though everything you do,
you should be able to categorize
and think of it as a rule.
So for example, for example,
if you're watching this
class not live but on video
and there are 3 million
views of this class,
and every single person who
watches it sends me an email
and expects me to respond,
the rule that you are creating is that
Timothy Snyder should spend 60 years
responding to your emails.
I've done the math.
(students laugh)
So that's an example of Kantian reasoning.
If you think it would be a good world
in which Timothy Snyder spent
no time with his children,
didn't sleep, didn't eat,
did no research,
but responded to emails
for the next 60 years,
then what you should do individually
is write me an email and
expect me to respond.
I say that with a smile, I
appreciate your nice emails,
but just think about the rule
that it would be created.
So then to think of a different rule.
If every time someone watched
a video from this class,
they made a donation to Razom, R-A-Z-O-M,
you would be creating
a rule that Ukrainians
should get warm clothing over the winter.
Or if every time you watched
a video of this class,
you went to my United24
site and made a donation,
you'd be making a rule
that Ukrainians can protect
themselves from drones.
So there are lots of rules
that you can make, right?
It's up to you.
Okay. That was Kant.
(students laughing)
That was Kant.
So even those of you haven't
taken intellectual history
are now gonna remember Kant
and acting as though all of
your actions create a rule.
Okay.
So Kant is the great
18th century philosopher,
So you'll remember that the
Prussians and the Hapsburgs
are rivals for the
unification of Germany, right?
They're rivals for the
unification of Germany
and it's the Prussians,
surprisingly, who win.
They beat the Hapsburgs
in the war in 1866.
They unified Germany then
they beat the French in 1870,
and then they unified Germany
at the Hall of Mirrors in Versailles.
They sign a treaty unified
Germany in January of 1871.
So that's where Germany comes into being.
But even in those decades,
it's less Germany and
more the Hapsburg monarchy
that matters for Ukraine, right?
Insofar as there's a German
factor in Ukrainian history
in the 1870s, 1880s, 1890s, 1900s,
it's the one that we studied
under the rubric of the Hapsburgs.
When the German language comes into
what's now Western Ukraine,
it's by way of the Hapsburgs.
When the idea of enlightenment comes in,
it's by way of the Hapsburgs, precisely.
I say I warm you all up with this
just because I want you to see
how drastic the change is in
the 20th century when it comes.
In the First World War,
as we've already seen,
there is a moment when Germany
controls most of Ukraine.
There's a moment in 19,
from early 1918 to the middle of 1918
when Germany and the Hapsburgs together
control most of Ukraine,
occupy most of Ukraine.
Theoretically, what they are doing
is national self-determination.
So this whole, this national
self-determination business
as you know and as
you've seen in this class
can work out in lots of different ways.
The German version of national
self-determination was
we are going to recognize you.
No one else is going to
recognize you but we will.
And in exchange we want you
to deliver X million amount,
X million tons of grain.
And then in practice
that grain was very often
forcibly requisitioned
from Ukrainian peasants
who very successfully
resisted those requisitions.
So, what the Germans were
after and the Austrians too
was food from Ukraine in 1918
which would allow them to
win the First World War.
That's very crucial to the First World War
and what comes next.
It's not the kind of thing which we,
if you're studying the war
from a British or French
or American point of view
you're gonna be thinking about
Ukraine and the food
and that the Germans might win in 1918.
But from the point of view of
Central and Eastern Europe,
this idea that Ukraine was a
(speaks in foreign language),
that Ukraine was like an endless
chamber filled with food, right?
Like it was a barn, a cornucopia.
It was an endless supply of food.
That notion is very important, right?
Because the idea that a land
is not about its people,
but it's about all the things
you can extract from it
is a very attractive colonial idea.
And that idea is only
going to be intensified
in the mind of a German soldier
who served not on the Eastern
but on the western front,
and that would be Adolf Hitler.
So, the way that Adolf
Hitler thinks about Ukraine
becomes intensely important
in 1941, '42, 1943
because that's when
Germany's going to invade
the Eastern Europe again.
I wanna step back here and
try to give you a portrait
of how Hitler saw Ukraine
and how he came to power and then what,
then we'll see what the
Germans actually did.
So there is one way in which
what happens in the east affects Hitler.
He's not a soldier in the east
but he does have this general idea
that German soldiers generally have
which was that we didn't
lose the war in the east
which they didn't.
They didn't lose the war in the east.
What happened in the east?
Well, the version of what
happened in the east that they get
is very often coming from
refugees coming from the east.
So namely from the people
we call white Russians
which is kind of an unfortunate
name in a number of ways
but by white Russian what is meant are
the people who are fighting
for the restoration of
the empire and lost.
And so now many of them end
up in France or in Germany.
And some of these white Russian emigres
bring with them an interesting idea about,
interesting for Hitler I mean,
interesting idea about
Bolshevism, about communism,
which is that it is all a Jewish plot.
So this for Hitler and for
the development of German
extreme right ideology
is a very important piece
of what turns out to be
Hitler's coherent worldview.
Up until that time,
Hitler had been saying that the Jews
were responsible for capitalism, right?
That capitalism was a Jewish conspiracy.
After 1919 or so, he begins also to say
that the Jews are
responsible for communism.
And the reason and so then this
is sort of an old punchline,
like how can they be both the
capitalist and the communists?
But from Hitler's point of view,
this isn't actually contradictory at all
because what Hitler argues
in his book "Mein Kampf"
is that the Jews are
responsible for all ideas
which allow humans to regard
one another as humans.
And so, capitalism with its
social contract and so on,
capitalism with its contracts,
capitalism with its legal
recognition and so on
is one way that we see each
other in non-racial terms.
Likewise, communism with
its class solidarity
and its idea of revolution and so on
is a way of seeing ourselves
in non-racial terms.
For Hitler, any way of seeing
ourselves in non-racial terms
is Jewish and anti-human and anti natural.
So the Jews are responsible
also for Christianity.
I mean, you can multiply,
I mean there may be a stronger
argument there actually
but you can multiply the list of things
that Jews are responsible for.
They're responsible in Hitler's mind
for any notion which sets us
apart from racial competition.
Because for Hitler, and
this is a crucial thing,
the racial competition is nature.
That's the way we're supposed to be.
We are divided up into races,
races are like species.
They shouldn't be interbreeding,
they should just be starving
one another to death.
That is good, that's natural.
That's the way nature is supposed to work.
That's what the future's
going to look like.
And that's going to be
as good as things get.
So, how does this lead to Ukraine?
Oh, so just to make this clear,
this is why Hitler's
antisemitism is so intense
because what he's saying
about the Jews is not,
as you sometimes read,
he's not saying they're
like racially inferior
or anything like that.
What he is saying is that the Jews
have a kind of supernatural
power to turn the humans
into non-racial brain slaves basically
with their communism,
with their capitalism,
with their Christianity,
with whatever it might be.
They come and they take the healthy humans
who should be engaged in
racial combat the entire time
'cause that's what they're
supposed to be doing,
that's what nature says,
and turn them into beings who are capable
of conversation and so on, right?
So, the Jews have spoiled nature.
He's very clear about this.
And what follows from
that is that the Jews
then have to be removed from the planet
one way or another, right?
They rule by way of ideas
and you can't extract the
ideas from everyone's mind
without physically
getting rid of the Jews.
All this logic is entirely clear
and explicit in "Mein Kampf."
What does it have to do with Ukraine?
Has a lot to do with Ukraine.
Because the racial element
of all this leads to Ukraine.
From Hitler's point of view,
Ukraine is Lebensraum
Like Lebensraum is
one of these German words
that you have to know.
It just means living
space or habitat, right?
So, in ecological context
it would just mean habitat.
So Lebensraum means
like, oh, or ecological niche.
Like it's where a species,
or in Hitler's mind, a race belongs.
Living space.
It literally means living
space, space for life.
Ukraine is the best Lebensraum
because it has the most
fertile territory, right?
It has the most productive
agricultural soil,
the black earth.
And therefore the Germans should be there
because the Germans are the superior race.
And if the Germans are not there,
then that requires some explanation
which appeals to the Jewish factor, right?
So the reason the Germans are not there,
the reason we lost the First
World War, for example,
is that there was a Jewish conspiracy,
the Jews stabbed us in
the back behind the lines.
Whatever it might be, right?
The Jews were behind the
British and their blockade.
Whatever it might be.
If the Germans have not achieved
what they should be achieving,
it must be the fault of the Jews.
So the idea of (speaking German)
leads directly to Ukraine.
Hitler's notion is that
Germany's gonna become
a large empire or a frontier empire.
He compares it to the United
States more than once.
The idea is that Germany is
gonna control a frontier,
dominate a frontier,
and the central part of that frontier
is going to be Ukraine.
Ukraine is also very important
in the antisemitic part of this analysis.
Why?
Because Hitler thinks it's going to be
relatively easy to seize Ukraine.
Why?
Because in his way of seeing the world,
the Soviet Union is a kind
of Jewish empire, right?
From his point of view, the
communists are all Jews,
the Jews are all communists,
and therefore the Soviet state
is a kind of Jewish exploitation of
the simple Slavic and other masses, right?
The simple Slavic and other masses,
those are the racially inferior people
from Hitler's point of view,
incapable of politics,
incapable of serious culture,
ripe for colonization.
Not capable of anything
besides being colonized.
But they will probably
prefer German colonization
to Jewish colonization.
And Hitler's ideas about this are quite,
I mean, they're really straightforward.
We'll come, we may be
starving them to death.
Actually we're planning to starve
tens of millions of them to death.
But if we give them
beads, they'll be happy.
And also if we have,
if we put up a pole in
the middle of the village
and put a radio on it and play
music, they'll be astonished
and they'll dance around the
pole and they'll be happy.
That sort of thing, right?
That sort of thing.
His notion is that the Soviet Union
seems strong but it's weak.
And the reason it's weak is that
it's just governed by the Jews.
The Jews govern with ideas.
And if you hit them with violence,
the whole edifice will collapse
and then the happy masses will
accept a new colonial master
because it's better than
the old colonial master.
I note the strong structural
resemblance of this
to the Russian war planning of late 2021
where the assumption again was that
there wasn't really Ukrainian state,
there was just a kind of exotic elite
which was perching on top,
and one burst of violence would
destroy that exotic elite.
And then the happy masses would accept
a new colonial master, okay?
Closed parenthesis.
So both by way of the antisemitism
and by way of a (speaking German),
Hitler's ideas lead directly to Ukraine.
Very briefly, how does
Hitler come to power?
How does Hitler come to power?
How does Hitler come to Ukraine?
One of the nice things about
teaching Ukrainian history
instead of German history
is that I don't have
to spend all this time
on like German public opinion
and like all these debates, ugh.
That's in another class.
No, it's an important thing
because if you take a class,
okay, now I'll make a serious point.
If you take a class about Nazi Germany
or about the Holocaust,
it's gonna be about
Germany, Germany, Germany,
Germany, Germany, Germany, Germany.
And the thing about that
is that there aren't that
many Jews in Germany,
and most of them survive.
And so, if you wanna be serious
about understanding the Holocaust,
you have to understand something about
the countries beyond Germany
where the Jews actually lived
like Poland or like Ukraine
or like Belarus, or like Lithuania
or Hungary or Czechoslovakia, right?
So I'm giving Germany far too
short shrift here, of course,
but there is a kind of
justification for all of this,
which is that you can't actually
figure out the Holocaust
just by looking at
Germany and German Jews.
You have to move into German colonization
and the German destruction
or attempt to destroy neighboring states
because that's where the
territory is where Jews live
and that's where the
territory is that Jews die.
So I'm gonna give this the
rise, Hitler's rise to power,
very short shrift.
The one factor which enables
it is the Great Depression.
Germany is formed as a republic.
It is a moderately successful
republic in the 1920s.
It has a hard time with
the Great Depression
in which 6 million people
roughly are unemployed.
Political factor.
The left is divided
between the socialist party
and the communist party.
That makes it much easier
for Hitler to come to power.
This, by the way, is a sort of universal
tactical political lesson
that the 21st century is
supposed to take from the 20th,
which is that when there's
a far right threat,
the left should not be divided, right?
No, I mean that,
I mean, like I'm just stating what is out.
Like that's something, that is a lesson
that people, 21st century tacticians
have tried to learn from the 20th century,
and this is sort of exhibit A of this.
Now, the reason why the German
left was divided is a bit,
is interesting from our point of view
because the German left had to be divided
because the German
communists were not permitted
to cooperate with the German socialists.
The German communists were
told what to do by Moscow
and because...
How does this hook up?
It hooks up because at
this time the Soviet Union
is trying to build
socialism in one country.
It has to defend itself, right?
It very nervously looks on the actions
of communist parties in Europe.
And what it tells them to do
is almost always determined
by what it thinks Soviet
security interests are.
And those things change, right?
But they don't change in a
way which makes it very easy
for communist parties to do
well inside their own countries,
let alone take power.
So the socialists are divided,
that's another important thing.
The third important thing
is that the German republic
had already significantly
compromised itself.
It was being run largely
by emergency decrees.
The parliament had already
been largely marginalized.
So, when Hitler is named as
chancellor in early 1933,
he inherits a situation where
executive power was already inflated,
legislative power had been suppressed,
and all he really needed
was one good crisis,
which he got with the Reichstag fire,
the burning of the German parliament,
which he uses to declare
a state of emergency,
which stays in power until until he dies.
By the summer of 1933,
they've established primitive
concentration camps.
They're hunting the
socialists and the communists
and the Nazis are the only legal party.
From our point of view,
the more interesting shift
or equally interesting
is the shift in foreign affairs.
Where to put it slightly brutally,
much of Europe swings in the direction
of this new Nazi German state.
That's not how people like to
talk about it in retrospect.
In retrospect, we were
all in the resistance.
We're always all in the
resistance in retrospect, right?
But at the time, this
seemingly innovative, dynamic,
new German colossus drew a
lot of positive attention
even when it wasn't positive.
People compromised in its
direction one way or another.
So, the Germans rearmed
and nobody stopped them.
The Germans took back some territory
that the French were
supposed to be occupying.
Nobody stopped them.
The East European countries,
which if you'll remember from
what I said about Poland,
the East European countries
who are having a hard time
as agrarian economies
during the depression,
some of them tend towards Germany
because Germany is the rare country
right in the middle of
Europe, then as now,
which needs to import food,
but it has lots of
industrial goods to export.
And so Germany makes deals
with Hungary and Romania
in which they agree to buy
German industrial output,
and Germany agrees to buy
their food at a certain price,
which during the depression
is incredibly attractive.
In March of 1938,
everyone looks away as
Austria is absorbed by Germany
in the famous Anschluss
which is another one of those
German words you have to know.
In September of 1938,
Italy, Great Britain,
France, and Germany
agree that Czechoslovakia
has to be partitioned
in Germany's favor
in the famous agreement at Munich
which the Czechs always call
the zrada
the betrayal at Munich.
So in all of these different ways
which I'm just kind of skimming over,
everyone is tilting towards Germany,
if not necessarily ideologically
then maybe economically.
But if economically, the
ideologically tends to follow.
Not necessarily ideologically
but maybe geopolitically.
But then once you've made
the geopolitical deal
then maybe your partner
isn't so unreasonable,
and maybe the Bolsheviks are much worse
which is how a lot of
people saw it at the time.
But speaking of the Bolsheviks,
the most radical tilt
towards Germany was 1939
when the Soviets and the Germans signed
in August and September in
two different agreements,
a de facto military
alliance and agreement,
an agreement how to occupy
Poland and the Baltic,
and the Baltic states.
So everyone looking back,
we all resisted of course looking back
and then looking back, everyone
has a different history.
But there is this general drift
which interestingly often
braces almost everybody
in some way or another
from the British to the
Soviets to the French.
Everyone is drifting in
some way towards Germany.
And this only stops or this
only changes tone I should say
when someone agrees to fight a war.
And that someone in this case
agrees to fight a war is kind
of a strange way to put it,
but the country that
resists Germany is Poland.
And this matters hugely
for Ukrainian history.
It's hard to say exactly how
but the reason why it matters is that
Hitler's plan for Ukraine was
we ally, we the Germans ally with Poland.
And together with Poland,
we invade the Soviet Union.
After which of course we
marginalize the Poles,
keep them under control,
occupy their country, whatever.
But that's the basic idea.
The war for Hitler is the war in the East.
This is something that's very hard
for Western people to understand.
Like if I say that France was
a second rate concern for Hitler
and that he didn't wanna
fight the British at all,
people don't...
Obviously now it's very important
in French and British memory
but from Hitler's point of
view, that was secondary.
The only reason he needed
to fight the French
from his point of view was to make sure
that he didn't have a second front
when he went to Eastern Europe.
That's why he had to fight the French.
And he only had to fight the British
because they came in on the
side of, oh yes, the Poles.
Okay, so the reason why the Poles
are so important in the story is that
by not agreeing to be a German ally,
they force Hitler to change his plans.
And how does Hitler change his plans?
He changes his plans by hastily making
an alliance with the Soviet Union.
Not what he meant to do, right?
But he does so in August
and September of 1939.
So instead of invading the Soviets
with the Poles as an ally,
he invades Poland with
the Soviets as an ally
in September of 1939, right?
Not how he meant for it to happen.
But because it happened that way,
then Ukrainian history
will take a certain turn
which I'm gonna return
to in just a second.
I wanna repeat the thing
I said a moment ago.
If the Poles don't fight in 1939
then it's unclear at what point the French
or the British ever would've
gotten into the war.
Because the reason the
French and the British
got into the Second World War was that
they had by that time given
Poland a security guarantee
which they honored in a very abstract way.
The French, this is literally true.
The French went into
Germany a couple of miles
and then pulled back out,
and so then they had technically honored
the terms of their agreement
to set up a second front.
The British didn't do anything at first
but they waited for a
while, decided what to do.
But the crucial thing is
they got into the war.
And if the British and the French
don't get into the war in 1939,
it's unclear when they would
ever have gotten into the war.
And if the British don't get into the war,
it's very, very unclear how the Americans
ever get into the war.
Maybe the Americans get into a war
in Asia with the Japanese,
but without Britain it's
hard to see how Roosevelt
gets the Americans into the war in Europe.
It's hard to see what line leads to that.
And if the Americans don't
get into the war in Europe,
it's not only just that you don't have
the Americans fighting,
it's also that you
don't have the Americans
supplying the Soviets
which is a huge X factor
which everyone forgets about
'cause it's very inconvenient.
But the reason why the Soviets
or one of the reasons why the Soviets
were able to hold back the Germans at all
was that the Americans
were hugely supplying them
with Studebaker and Jeeps
and all kinds of other things
across the Pacific Ocean.
So, if the Poles don't fight in 1939,
it's a very different world war.
I just wanna just note that
and now we'll go back to Ukraine, okay?
So for Ukrainian history,
what this means is that we get
this strange period from 1939 to 1941
of what you could think of
as Molotov-Ribbentrop Europe,
Molotov-Ribbentrop were the
commissar for foreign Affairs,
the foreign minister of the
Soviet Union and of Germany.
They're the ones who signed
the pact, August 23, 1939.
The notorious, people call
it the Hitler-Stalin Pact.
The Molotov-Ribbentrop Pact
is usually what it's called.
This creates a world where
for almost two years,
the Soviets and the
Germans are de facto allies
and the country and most
significantly for our region,
the country of Poland is destroyed.
Poland wiped off the map.
The Poles resist the
Germans for about six weeks
with actually much more
skill and dedication
than they're usually given credit for,
taking significant losses.
But they're facing an
army attacking them from,
not only from the west,
but from the north,
from Prussia.
Sorry about the geography.
But Germany actually was north of Poland
as well as west of Poland
because of Prussia.
They were also attacking from the south
because Czechoslovakia
had been dismantled.
And Slovak soldiers joined in the invasion
on the German side.
And Czech tank, the Czechs had the best
military industry at the time.
The best tanks, best explosives.
So the Germans were invading
Poland with Czechoslovak tanks.
All of that mitigated against Poland
even before, so the Soviet Union joined
in the invasion on the 17th of September.
So the Polish state is destroyed
which is not a trivial thing.
It wasn't actually, it's
not actually normal.
It seems normal, I mean,
again, there's a parallel here with 2022
and the idea of the state doesn't exist
and destroy the state, right?
But it's not actually
normal to invade countries
and then say they don't exist
unless you're a colonizing power.
So Europeans constantly invaded countries
and then said they didn't exist.
That's the history of the
Americas and Africa, right?
But for European countries
to invade other European countries
and say that they didn't
exist, that was something new.
And that's what the, both the Germans
and the Soviets did that with Poland.
They invaded the country
then they said it didn't really exist.
And therefore, this is important,
what we're doing is not an occupation
because you can only occupy a country.
Which may just seem like a word game
but it's actually, it's a legal maneuver
or an extra legal maneuver.
Because if there's not a country there,
then what you're doing
is not an occupation.
You're not bound by
the laws of occupation,
by the conventions on occupation,
by the customs of occupation.
You're just saying that where you are
is a kind of undefined place
inhabited by autochthonous peoples, right,
who we don't really know very much about.
That is the German legal approach
to the invasion of Poland.
The Soviet approach was
a little bit different.
The Soviet approach was that
there was a class war going on.
The Ukrainian and the
Belarusian peasants
were being oppressed by the Polish lords.
The Polish state had collapsed
and therefore we just came
in to aid our class allies.
But again, the Soviets
were also careful to say
that there wasn't a Polish state anymore.
The Polish state they
claimed had been destroyed.
This wasn't an occupation,
this was just territory
where there was a class war going on.
So, from the point of
view of Ukrainian history,
what follows is that the
Ukrainian Soviet republic
expands very significantly to the west,
pretty much to the
borders that it has now.
The Molotov-Ribbentrop borders of 1939
are pretty much identical
to the western borders
of the independent Ukrainian state now.
Another thing which happens
on these territories
is a kind of rapidly,
like a fast forward version
of the Bolshevik policies
from 1917 to the 1930s.
There the territories are next
and then there are four
waves of deportations.
The deportations tend to affect above all
people associated with the Polish state.
So more Poles than anybody else,
although later on there
are quite a few Jews
who didn't wanna take Soviet passports.
But the basic idea is
destroy the Polish state
and then take the people
who have anything to do
with the Polish state.
The colonists, the landowners,
the bureaucrats, the
soldiers, the foresters,
and get those people to Kazakhstan.
Get them to Kazakhstan,
get them to Siberia
where they won't cause any trouble.
And then the notion was that
now we're carrying out a revolution
and so we are going to
transfer land from these people
to the oppressed Ukrainian
and Belarusian peasants.
This revolution is really for you.
Which is if you'll remember,
that's a lot like the
1920s in the Soviet Union
where the peasants are brought in,
invited into the revolution
by the notion that they're gonna get land.
And as you remember, the most
important political question
in this part of the world
in the first half of the 20th century
is precisely land.
So the terrain is de-Polandized.
Poles are deported from it
and Poles lose their land
which is a bit like what had
happened in 1937, in 1938.
If you did the reading
in chapter three I think
it is of "Bloodlands,"
the most important national
action in the Soviet terror
was the Polish action in which 100,000
or around 100,000 Poles were shot.
About twice as many were deported.
And so, Poles are being
removed from these terrains
where historically there
had been Poles, right,
in sort of wave after wave after wave.
But I said this was accelerated.
Not long after that in 1940,
so the peasants get the land in early 1940
and then collectivization
starts in late 1940.
So, the stage is very short
and peasants are generally disillusioned
by collectivization.
And even many West Ukrainian communists
are disillusioned by this.
The West Ukrainian communists
who had been part of the
Polish Communist Party
had been telling their people that
Soviet Ukraine is Ukrainian state,
that you're all gonna get land,
and our national culture
is going to be respected.
Collectivization disillusioned them.
The fake elections also
disillusions many of them.
And they tend to fade from
any kind of significance in the region.
The reason I mention that
is to try to suggest something
which is gonna be important
in the next lecture,
which is that there had been
Ukrainian political life.
Not in the Soviet Union,
right, but in Poland.
It had been stunted and
oppressed but it existed.
There were Ukrainian churches,
there was Ukrainian civil society,
there was Ukrainian educational society,
there were Ukrainian cooperatives,
the Ukrainian newspapers.
All of that.
Under Soviet rule that
becomes impossible, right?
There is a Soviet, it's
called Soviet Ukraine
but independent forms of civil society
from whatever they might
be are not allowed.
The way that Leninism works is that
everything that one might
think of a civil society
has to be part of one larger structure,
has to be part of the
state or of the party.
So all of the legal political parties
that had existed under
Poland are now dissolved.
The communists are now discredited
which leaves who?
Hmm?
- Jewish nationalists.
- Okay, among Ukrainian political parties.
- [Student] The nationalists.
- The nationalists, right?
The situation has selected
for the nationalists.
And you'll see why
that's important later on
but I just wanna mark it right now.
Okay.
So, the last stage of this
and where I'm gonna leave you
is Operation Barbarossa itself.
Which is the Operation Barbarossa
is the invasion of the Soviet Union.
It's when Hitler finally
gets to do the thing
which he wanted to do which
is invade the Soviet Union,
try to seize Ukrainian grain,
also try to seize the
Azerbaijani oil fields,
that's a secondary objection.
Destroy the Soviet state as such.
There are three larger policies
attached to this invasion
that are formulated by the Germans.
The first is what they
call the Final Solution,
which is initially the idea
that the Jews will somehow
be deported out of the way
to Madagascar or to Siberia, who knows,
but somehow made to vanish.
The final solution over
the course of this war
will become more
immediate, more proximate,
and more directly lethal.
Over the course of the war,
it will move from this kind
of vague notion of deportation
to killing them first over pits
and then eventually in gas chambers.
The second larger policy is
what they call the Hunger Plan.
By the terms of the Hunger Plan,
the Germans were going to keep
the Stalinist collective farm.
They were going to try
to control Ukrainian
and general Soviet agriculture
but direct the surpluses from
Ukraine to Germany, right?
In a way, the same dream
of the First World War,
direct the surpluses, colonial exploit.
Direct the surpluses from
Ukraine back to Germany
and to the rest of Europe.
And this will also be carried out
in the sense that cities
are going to be starved,
most notably Leningrad
which is in Soviet Russia,
but also tens of thousands
of people will die
in Ukrainian cities such
as Kharkiv and Kyiv.
It's carried out most notably
in the prisoner of war camps
where through early 1942,
the Germans carry out a policy
of deliberately starving
Soviet prisoners of war,
almost regardless of ethnicity.
Some ethnicities are treated
a little bit differently than others.
Jews are treated much worse.
But in general, Soviet
prisoners of war starved.
About 3.1 million die of
hunger and related diseases
which is a huge number,
it's a terrifying number.
By the end of, at the end of 1941,
this was actually the
most lethal German policy.
More people were starved to death
in these open air prison, not even camps,
so just enclosures where people
are left to die basically.
Camp in a way dignifies it too much.
More people had died this
way than in the Holocaust
as of the end of 1941.
In 1942, the Holocaust, the
Final Solution will pass
in part because the Germans begin to think
they have to recruit
people from these camps
in order to do various
kinds of police work
and other work for them.
Which by the way means that
many of the local
collaborators in the Holocaust
had been extracted from
these camps, right,
which gives you a sort of sense
of some of the choices that
or non-choice that people faced.
The third major policy
was called Generalplan Ost
and that was the larger
notion of colonization
that over the course of the next decades,
tens of millions of Slavs
would be moved out of the way,
starved or dispersed,
what we would call ethnically cleansed.
The Jews by now would be
gone some way or another
and Germany would establish
a whole series of nice small towns,
everything very well-organized,
white picket fences.
The Ukrainians or the Slavs
significantly reduced in numbers
but working as de facto slaves.
That was the basic idea,
that was the blueprint.
They never got there, right,
because they lost the war.
The Holocaust which is the
last thing I wanna talk about
is the one of these three policies
which actually, so to speak,
is worse than it was planned, right?
The general idea was that
we're going to starve out
everybody or disperse everybody
that the Germans are never
quite able to do that.
They do starve quite a
large number of people,
as you see in "Bloodlands."
They do disperse quite
a large number of people
but the most focus killing policy
and the one that accelerates
consistently over the course
of the war is the Holocaust.
So I just wanna leave you with
a couple of thoughts about it
and then we'll be done.
The first thought about this is that
the Holocaust has to do with
not only Hitler's general idea
that the Jews are
responsible for everything,
but the particular idea
which follows from this,
that if we're losing the war,
it must be the fault of the Jews.
So for example, if we
invade the Soviet Union
and the British and the Americans
come in on the side of the Soviets,
that must be explained not by
Pearl Harbor or anything else,
it must be explained by the
fact that the Jews are in charge
on Wall Street and Fleet Street,
as well as in the Kremlin, right?
So, defeat in war makes the
conspiracy theory more necessary
and more pervasive.
And also it should be said
more sociologically useful
to the German population as a whole.
The conspiratorial antisemitism
becomes more important
for Germans during the war,
especially after they start to lose.
So this is specific to the end of 1941.
When Germany,
when it's clear that the
Germans have lost the war
that they planned to fight which is 1941,
that's when Hitler shifts the idea
that all the Jew are to be
killed, late 1941, early 1942.
When I say the German,
the war they thought
they were gonna fight,
this is very important, right?
So this is not a military history class.
You've heard me bemoan
that there's not enough military history.
I'm just gonna make one
little military history point
which is that the wars never go the way
you think they're gonna go.
They never go the way you
think they're gonna go.
And looking back, it's almost impossible
to overstate just how
dramatic that truth is.
The Germans invaded the Soviet Union
thinking that it would
fall within 12 weeks
on the outside.
Six to 12 weeks, the Soviet
Union was going to collapse.
All of their preparations
were made on that assumption.
They didn't have supply lines planned,
they didn't bring winter clothing.
The whole assumption is that
this is gonna collapse within
a couple of months, right?
And of course it didn't do that
and they couldn't admit that they failed,
and they kept fighting
and so on as one does.
And they blame someone else
and that's part of the history
of the Holocaust, right?
But it's irrelevant for
the politics of all this.
When I say they didn't,
they lost the war they
thought they were fighting,
that's what I mean, right?
They expected the Soviet Union to collapse
in a couple of months.
The World War from Hitler's point of view
is the war that happens
because they didn't destroy
the Soviet Union immediately.
Their thought was the Soviet
Union falls immediately.
There's nothing anyone can do about it.
But it turned out that was not true.
The second point I wanna
make about the Holocaust
and then we'll be done is that
even in the Holocaust,
and this is the reading in "Black Earth"
which I hope you'll do carefully,
but even in the Holocaust,
or I should say even
especially in the Holocaust,
there's never a moment when
politics ceases to matter.
There's never a moment where
you get into some sphere
of pure evil or pure ethics or something
where human experience and
human calculations don't matter.
The way that people behave
during the Holocaust
has to do not just with German intentions
and German policies of mass killing,
but also with their own calculations
about what might work
out the best for them.
And in the case of the
population of the Soviet Union,
of the prewar Soviet Union
where this is most relevant
is Hitler's idea that Jews are communists
and communists are Jews.
Now, most Soviet citizens know that
there are certainly some
anti-Semites in the Soviet Union
but in general, most Soviet
citizens know that's not true
because it's kind of their
everyday experience, right?
Like they're communists, right?
The vast majority of communists
were actually not Jews, right?
And if you're in the Soviet
Union, you know that.
But the politics of this is
that if the Germans come
into the Soviet Union
and they say, all the communists were Jews
and you're a communist,
what do you say?
I mean, unless you're heroic or you fled,
you say, yes, they were.
Right?
Because that shifts the
responsibility from you
for this thing which is supposedly doomed
communism onto the Jews.
That's a form of politics, right?
The Germans were fooled by this.
They sort of fooled themselves
and other people fooled them.
But that's a form of politics.
The Germans come in with an
idea of the way the world works.
People adapt to that idea
of the way the world works
in a way that suits them
by shifting the responsibility
for the Soviet system onto the Jews.
That's part of the
history of the Holocaust.
And then of course, in the
Soviet Union as elsewhere,
the vast majority of the work
that's done in the Holocaust
is not done by the Germans.
It's done by local people.
And in taking part in this policy,
they're also expressing a
kind of personal commitment
to a certain view of the world,
which is that the Jews are communists,
the communists are Jews,
the Soviet Union has to be destroyed.
All of this is incredibly awkward
after Soviet power comes back.
And how Stalinism deals with all of this,
this very messy record of collaboration
and resistance during the Holocaust
and during Soviet occupation in general,
how Stalinism deals with this
is gonna be our subject
when we come back next week.
So, thank you very much.
(gentle music)